dans cette entreprise loir-etienne
depuis 30 ans ont cultive les plantes
qui vont servir à l'aménagement des
toits végétalisés dans ces bacs en
plastique quatre ingrédients des billes
d'argile un feutre du substrat et enfin
des graines et des jeunes pousses de
succulentes après 5 à 6 mois en
pépinière ces modulaire pourront être
installés sur les toits un moyen de
limiter le réchauffement des bâtiments
nos plantes mais comme elles le font
d'un point de vue naturel comme dans une
prairie naturelle elles évaporent et
quand on évapore on évapore de l'eau on
rafraîchit le support donc le toit du
bâtiment une belle journée d'été il va
être rafraîchi de 25 degrés ça c'est en
surface entre toiture dans les salles
sous les toits on va gagner entre 4 et 5
degrés un après-midi ensoleillé à
l'occasion des JO de Paris 2024
l'entreprise a été sollicitée pour
équiper 12 bâtiments du village des
athlètes soit 8000 mètres carrés de
toiture et la pas question de
l'installer que des supports végétalisés
une autre solution plus complète a été
proposée
on a développé donc des toitures
végétalisées innovantes et notamment des
toitures métallisées qui sont capables
au-delà du simple végétal de stocker la
pluie et de valoriser l'eau de pluie on
a aussi l'intégration des panneaux
solaires on peut donc sur le même
support sur un toit de bâtiment
classique on peut avoir la végétation la
gestion de la pluie et la pluie ça
devient une ressource essentielle en
ville et la production photovoltaïque un
marché à plus d'un million d'euros qui
devrait donner un nouveau coup de
projecteur à cette entreprise familiale
et à ses 60 salariés avec la loi climat
et résilience de nouveau débouchés sont
également envisageables à terme tous les
nouveaux bâtiments de plus de 1000
mètres carrés devront avoir au moins 30%
de leur surface en toiture végétalisée
ou panneaux solaires